i want to tell you about something else
that happened today because we think it
tells you a lot about where this country
is moving
when you were growing up you probably
learned one of the most basic moral
principles that there is you ought to
treat other people as individuals for
who they are
not on the basis of how they look or who
their parents are what their parents did
you had to judge people for what they do
and what they say for the choices they
make
that was a good principle we haven't
always followed it as individuals or as
a country but we ought to try to follow
it as best we can
our hardest because bigotry diminishes
and hurts people it's pretty simple
and yet somehow over time the
institutional left has decided to reject
that idea
and embrace a standard that is both new
and time worn
you may have assumed that race guilt
collective punishment
moral purity based on bloodline you
thought those were discredited ideas
creepy relics of a darker time it turns
out they're not
turns out the new york times
wholeheartedly embraces those ideas
so does much of the left yesterday the
times announced it was hiring a woman
called sarah jong to write about
technology for the paper
within hours readers discovered jong's
twitter feed which she had not bothered
to delete
apparently because she was not
embarrassed by it
judging by what she wrote on twitter
sarah jong is an angry bigot and not
in a subtle way here are some examples
of her tweets quote
oh man it's kind of sick how much joy i
get out of being cruel to old white men
another quote dumb ass effing white
people marking up the internet with
their opinions like
dogs peeing on fire hydrants another
quote
hashtag cancel white people at one point
john tweeted a crude graph claiming that
as whiteness
increased so did awful later she said
that white people smell like dogs
here's another one quote white people
have stopped breeding
you'll all go extinct soon that was my
plan all along
and on and on well people are getting
fired for far less than this across
corporate america right now but the new
york times decided to double down
on sarah jong's behalf here's part of
the statement the paper sent out about
her
quote john's journalism and the fact she
is a young asian woman have made her a
subject of frequent online harassment
for a period of time she responded to
that harassment by imitating the
rhetoric
of her harassers in other words it's not
her fault
white racism caused sarah jong's racism
against white people
she's the victim here harvard graduate
oppressed
person that she is some of john's many
defenders in the press accused her
critics of taking her tweets out of
context but that's not true
we checked there's no context for these
tweets sarah john was furious at an
entire race of people
and she said so on twitter you think
somewhere on the left the last
responsible person would be cringing at
all of this it's also
ugly and awful in an earlier time it
would be considered indefensible but
modern progressives are happy not simply
to defend it but to attack anyone
who questions the joy that sarah john
derives from being cruel to white men
lydia paulgreen the editor-in-chief of
huffpo who was widely regarded by
her peers as a [ __ ] announced that
criticism of zhong is quote
part of a deeply troubling trend of
far-right agitators trying to get
journalists fired
far-right agitators okay but actually
we're not calling on zhong
to be fired we're not liberals so we
don't believe that every person we
disagree with ought to be crushed
including sarah john
we believe in free speech even when it's
reprehensible maybe especially when it
is
what we would like to see though is some
honesty let's all stop lying for a
minute
what sarah jong said was wrong but it
was only shocking because she expressed
it so clearly
in point of fact her views are
commonplace in the american
establishment maybe universal
try to find a single government
bureaucrat or college administrator or
head of corporate hr
who disagrees with the idea that people
should be judged by the color of their
skin
and that some races are more virtuous
and deserving than other races
they all think that every one of them
and yet remarkably
these very same people are the quickest
to cry racism
at the slightest provocation or for no
reason at all they think of themselves
as arch enemies
of racism they get tattoos on their arm
telling you that
and yet they're its chief purveyors deep
deep irony
how do they do that well simple they
redefine the term as vice.com succinctly
put it a couple of years ago quote
it is literally impossible to be racist
to a white person
pretty much the entire left now takes
that as a matter of faith they deeply
believe that
but what does that mean exactly is there
really an entire race of people
so repulsive so morally repugnant that
it is quote
literally impossible to wrong them you
could do anything to people like that
and not feel bad about it in fact why
wouldn't you
they deserve it they're not really human
the attitude it's not hard to guess
where ideas like that wind up we've seen
it
all of us should be afraid of it all of
us regardless of color there are plenty
examples in history of what happens when
people start thinking this way
and they're all sad it's awful and yet
this is the mindset the left has imposed
on our country
it's an attitude designed to dehumanize
the individual to erase what makes each
of us
interesting and distinct and vital and
reduce us to faceless members of a group
it's totalitarian we have to resist it
with everything that we have